Three of these are not polynomials, but
the rest of them are. We learned that a
polynomial is an expression that only uses
addition, subtraction, and multiplication
to combine constants variables. But this
first trace right here has a big division
sign in it, dividing one expression by
another expression. Now if we had either
the numerator or the denominator of this
fraction on its own, then both of them
would be polynomials. But because they're
divided, this is not a polynomial, so
we'll check that one off. We'll talk more
about expressions that look like this
later on the course. One of our other
important rules is that a polynomial must
have exponents in it that are only non
negative integers. Right here we have x to the 1/2
and 1/2 may be positive, but it's not an
integer, so that means that this is not a
polynomial. We can think about that rule
again when we look at this answer choice
right here, -6x^5+x^-3-11x+9.
All of these terms in here are fine for
being part of polynomials, except for this
one x^-3, because -3 is a negative integer
exponent, not a non-negative integer
exponent. So that means this expression is
not a polynomial. It may seem a little bit
funny that 6 counts as a polynomial. We
don't often talk about numbers or
variables on their own as polynomials, but
they technically do qualify since they do
fit our definition. We said that
polynomials could have just variables,
just constants, or both. So 6 and all
other constant terms are technically
polynomials. We're going to talk about
polynomials throughout the entire rest of
the course, so it's great to get a handle
on how to find them.